Staples Center. You as the security guard?
Yes. Just why?
Why, how?
That. You coming out at the Lakers
game dressed up as the as the on court
security.
That was a Staples Center security guard
outfit was given to me as a gift.
But it was Adam McKay and Chris Henchy.
Henchy gave me this full.
And because they know I like weird
costumes and.
And I opened the present, I was like,
Wow. Oh, man.
I don't know what they thought.
I was mad. They're like, Are you okay?
And I was like, No, this is great.
I just realized I have to wear it at a
Laker game though.
Oh, my God. So it wasn't even planned.
You just did it.
No. And so it took me, like, almost the
whole season for me to get up the guts
to. And I was like, How do I bring it?
I don't want to get kicked out, but I
don't want to tell the Lakers that I'm
doing it because it's not it's not the
same. It's not the same, it's not the
same.
So I bundled up the coat and I went
through, my ticket.
I wore the pants and the tie, and I was
sitting there. I was like, okay, let's
go time, pop the tie on, put my jacket
on.
You just stood there.
Just stood there out there with the guy.
At first I was on the court and the guy
was like, You can't be on the court.
I'm like, okay, can I just stand here?
He goes, Yeah, you can stand there.
I just stood there and just stared the
crowd down.
So for everybody watching this right
now, if you are not familiar with what
I'm talking about, if you go on.
Youtube, I think you can find clips of
it.
Google Will Ferrell.
As a staple security guard.
And he's just standing there in the full
security outfit and he's not moving.
And you see players like dribbling the
basketball behind him.
And you see Kobe there, they're in a
timeout. And Kobe's like, what?
Like, what is he doing?
And because at first they didn't.
But the whole section starts taking
photos of me and they stand up.
So they're reacting to that and they're
like, what are they looking at?
And they see me.
Then they put you on the big screen.
So I'm I'm thinking that I'm going to
get tackled.
I'm going to and then the time out's
done and I just sit back.
Just sit back down.
And I was with Henchey and we were like,
Wow, okay, nothing happened.
One of the best, one of the best
impromptu bits.
And I find out that the the security
guys are like. Hey.
Hey, man. We appreciate the shout out.
Hey. Hey.
It means a lot. You. You.
You had to act like that's what it was.
I was like, Yeah. No, guys, seriously.
I love what you guys do.
Let's got to hold you down.
Keep people in there. Somebody got to,
love it.
And then the best part was I get to tap
on the shoulder. So then we're sitting.
We still have, like, a whole nother
quarter left. Like, what do we do?
Do I stand up again?
Like, what do I just.
I'm in my security guard outfit and the
guy taps me on the shoulder and goes,
Shaq happened to be at the game, so
he's sitting baseline over in the
corner. And one of his guys is like
Shaq thought that was hilarious.
Do you during the next time out, do you
want to throw him out of the game?
Holy shit. Because he's ready to leave.
And I go, Oh, that's genius.
Yeah. Okay, I'll stand up and I'll
pretend. So the next time I stood up, I
keep looking over at Shaq and I keep
because we're like 30ft away from each
other. And he's looking.
He's like. And I'm like.
I'm like, uh, uh. Please.
And then. And then I keep.
He keeps getting my attention.
He's not doing anything.
And then finally, you're like, That's
it, Let's go.
Let's go. You toss him out of the game.
I throw him out of the game.
And then Shaq and I are hugging each
other and he's like, I'm like, That is
so funny that you.
He was like, Anytime you can throw me
out, anytime.
This is what makes it was hilarious.
Will Ferrell. Will Ferrell.